hi guys and welcome to an episode which
I'm kind of on the fence about it's
there's a couple of things that I think
are kind of wrong with this episode one
of the things is something which I've
already apologized for but I guess I can
do it again this time lapse includes
loads of placing things and then
removing them again and just in general
trying to get things to work because
this is basically the shape that I took
for the yard square at first but then I
kinda figured that it looked like a
jellyfish let me get let me get a
picture of this this thing basically
this thing I kind of felt like that it
looked like this thing it doesn't really
completely but still is too similar also
it's kind of like 4chan Slover in a way
so the general you don't want to mess
with either of those things so I don't
think that was really the best decision
so this thing is going to be replaced
anyway and there's a couple of other
things but one thing that was actually
happening in this episode is I finally
place the ride so that's something I
guess but yeah this is basically I had
to get this Square in before I moved on
to any of the actual themed areas of the
park
because I have an excellent park
planning with beautiful graphics as you
can see right here and according to this
plan I really had to get this Square
first see where all the roads go and
what kind of scenery I want to have
where and other things now speaking of
that scenery by the way you'll see that
I have called the general areas with
many different things like there's one
area for Italy Greece and Spain and
there's one area for Holland Belgium and
England and this doesn't mean that I
completely hates the cultures and just
think they're one and the same
I just want to assign general ish areas
so the area with Greece Italy and Spain
is going to be the Mediterranean area
and even though it's going to be one
area I do want to have some very small
sub areas so to speak in that one area
for example there might be one Greek
ride with some Greek buildings but then
at some other points in that area I'll
have an Italian ride with maybe some
Italian buildings so it's not going to
be all mixed but I kind of want that to
be their general areas and hopefully
that's actually going to work out don't
know exactly if it's going to work but I
hope so basically because I haven't
really messed around with that yet and
something that I'm definitely guilty of
is it's not really actually knowing some
the themes and according to some people
this is actually a really good thing
because I should kind of move out of my
comfort zone some people have actually
been suggesting Japanese for that but
surprisingly that was actually kind of
my comfort zone I just haven't released
anything with the theme yet but there
are just certain things that have never
been done before like I've only done a
Greek theme once but that was really
just very simple and a Spanish theme is
completely new to me but especially on
the Asian side of this thing there's
some news and there's some new stuff and
also Dutch is a theme that I've never
ever tried before I didn't want to get
it in here just because I'm from Holland
but because it would fit in the rest of
the park and I feel like it's a theme
which hasn't really been done justice in
a way that I would like to see it I mean
the the theme park is Dutch is something
that we've seen before but there's just
this general kind of Dutch architecture
with classical influences that I haven't
really seen in theme parks before so I
kind of want to try that but um that's
very off-topic
basically about the square I decided to
in the end go with a what's it called
again a chess swing that's the name
because I try to fountain at first but
that was just ugly and stupid and there
weren't any good fountains to be very
honest and I just wanted to have a ride
over here because you need something
yeah and this is something that many
people have been saying and you know I
guess I'm kind of aware of is that you
need something in the middle of your
park which you can see from the Main
Street which is kind of large that you
think are this is that's beautiful I'm
gonna walk towards that and I know it
sounds really stupid when I say it but
it's something that has to do with
psychology and complicated matters so I
won't delve too deep into that but
basically you want to have something
large at the end of the Main Street
that's what it boils down to and a
fountain is not really the type of thing
for that you usually just have that at a
small square some nice little pond or
something like that but not in the
middle of Main Street and the square
thingamajig so I have a fountain right
here right now but that is really just a
placeholder for the futures chair swing
speaking of which I had to make some
custom machinery for that and I'm still
on the fence of whether I actually want
to include the custom see me making on
the park I don't think so because I'm
quite quite it's not a beautiful process
and I really suck at it too
but just something that you may have
missed out on like whoa where that where
that object suddenly come from then
and that's because that happened I
suppose it's not something that you know
I really want to be too much like oh
look at this special custom sit really
but it's just something that I kind of
want it to have because I really can't
find all the pieces to everything all
the time and it just seemed like a cool
idea to have some custom scenery pieces
that go with the park and in the end
when it's all finished and hopefully I'm
actually happy about the park then the
custom scenery can be released too and
then everybody will be happy I suppose
at least that's my my dream plan right
here these planters in the middle are
just going to be filled with flowers and
trees and things like that at some point
at some point I really felt like the
square didn't look good like I was
really not happy about it these shapes
I'm still me too not too sure about it
somebody has somebody in the stream
actually said I see all right why don't
you make the the square asymmetrical and
I felt like yeah [ __ ] it
Yolo I'm just going to try that and at
some point I felt I felt that maybe that
wasn't the best decision but now I just
kind of have to roll with it anyway so
in the end you'll see that at least I
think the foliage kind of saved did the
area because it was really looking not
that good right now actually is when I
think it doesn't look that good also the
shapes of the plants was kind of looked
like some kind of anime person to me I
don't know why I saw that in that but
the bottom to kind of look like a scarf
or something in that in the middle could
be a face and then all the other things
are just like hair or something like
that
but it really only works with anime
because that's the only kind of medium
where people are stupid hairstyles in
any case as very off-topic a couple of
problems that I also had with this was
what kind of path covers I wanted to use
and what kind of borders I want to have
on them because at some point I think I
used branches borders on these things or
had some kind of curves that I didn't
really like and then I ended up
replacing those as well so there really
was a lot of experimentation in it and
I'm kind of sorry about that because I
really didn't want that to happen
because it doesn't result in the best
time I've just ever but in this case
especially because it's in the middle of
the park and this square serves such a
major purpose in the park I just kind of
wanted to work on it
until I got something that I actually
liked and that's why I read it so many
things and experimented with all kinds
of stuff and then ended up looking like
a complete and utter turd at some points
in the process but I think in the end it
it is hopefully going to kind of work
out right here now here's where not at
branches borders of which I at some
later stage think okay no [ __ ] that
that's not good not to mention that I
removed those planters wider oh right I
wanted to yeah I wanted to remake these
shapes because something really weird
was going on like seriously I measured I
measured it the tiles I counted the
tiles on both sides and it was
completely symmetrical like it was just
as big on the right side as on the left
side so I had to plant us do that and
then it ended up looking bigger than on
the left side and was really confused
about that but there must be like some
kind of visual problems going on there
or I miscounted it in any case I kind of
wanted to make those lenses on the left
side it's tiny bit smaller so it would
look more like an actual round square
that's actually where the middle is
actually in the middle because that's
not the way that it kind of looked and
there was a problem and that's kind of
why I wanted to fix that I think it's
actually kind of better right now with
those new textures I mean those new
shapes but it's really the the square as
a whole is still quite experimental like
there's loads of foliage in it in the
end and some weird shapes and usually
this type of thing would be symmetrical
I think in the Disney parks they are all
symmetrical so or at least kind of
symmetrical I know that in the gardens
on the sides aren't really but like
there's some kind of middle piece which
kind of works in a symmetrical way at
least more so than this thing but yeah I
think at this point is when I at the
chair swing oh my this was amazing in
the stream like and this is going to
completely [ __ ] up the time lapse I
probably done goofed at this point and
why did I add the carousel oh right that
happened first but in any case there
were so many things and there was a time
skip yeah because the game crashed a
huge number of times like I was in the
stream and it was just no SVD for as id
time off the time and everybody wishes
go claw you dun goofed mate and that was
not not a good time to be me but but now
I was actually still pretty funny but
and I suppose it kinda works out and the
the little chair swing is here finally
and it's a to stay hopefully the only
problem that I had with its the enormous
hitbox like as soon as you place one of
those CF h rights like in in a
thousand-mile area you're going to hit
that thing and you're going to not hit
anything else so you try removing some
custom scenery and you click on it
you're like on the other side of the
pike
yet it removes that freakin chair swing
as you can see also the custom steering
that it comes with is also it also has
that thing happening to it so it's kind
of unfortunate but not really too much
of a problem I suppose I really did stop
spitting on my pop-filter right oh my as
so not on topic so here is when I did
try to add something to that ferris
wheel the problem that I had with this
thing as this is not even a ferris wheel
what I'm talking about the chair swing
problem that I had is I wanted to have
some kind of round structure around it
but there are no roundcube path kind of
stairwell things so it was pretty much
impossible to get something like that so
at some point I just forget enough okay
I'm going to at least try this go into
Sketchup see if I can actually make
something that looks okay and then I
ended up with a poof that was magic and
suddenly that was that so I'm very sorry
about not adding that I forgot to record
right there for like a couple minutes so
that's what happened over there but you
know I think it kind of works out in the
end it's really not a good thing and
I've been messing with fences for a very
long time and I [ __ ] up every damn
time
so in the end I just decided to go with
something really simple it's really not
much but it kind of works and as long as
you get a couple of decorations around
it some lamps and some focus you can
actually make it look okay so and that
kind of happened and all these planters
will all get and yeah their own kind of
color thing not really sure in a high
sign if this is really the best idea to
do over here but basically I wanted to
have some kind of purple some kind of
red orange yellow and another I think it
was just green no it wasn't just green
it must've been mm [ __ ] I don't know
anymore probably pink to be very honest
yeah I think it was pink
but basically what kinds of different
colors where each planter is assigned to
one color and that's basically how those
things worked and as loads of mums over
here yeah there is a bit of repetition
when it comes to the flowers I really
don't
have too much experience when it comes
to filling in flower planted things like
this so if there's anybody with actual
gardening knowledge that has some
critique on this I'd be very willing to
accept it because I'm I'm really not
sure if this is the best way that I
could have done it
and there are probably a couple of
things that I definitely need to improve
on but in general I think it looks kind
of okay and it finally made the the
entire square look decent as well and
that's something that I really need it
because like at this point the square
has gone through so many redoing x' and
stuff like that that I really just felt
like [ __ ] it I'm just going to do it
this way and if it doesn't end up
working out I'll just kind of work with
it but not remove it or remove it once
again and try we reworking the entire
square because that happened so many
times that at this point how is fur
pretty you're pretty tired of that but I
am kind of happy about it yeah it's not
really too special in a way but I just
wanted something that's whoa don't quote
his new kind of thing basically the idea
with the square was really stupid and
pretentious I wanted to have a ride in
the middle which you could look at from
the Main Street but one thing I also
wanted to have since this is a park that
you know is if it's themed around
Eurasia and it even has a layout which
should at least do some extent also kind
of be the same as the actual layout of
Eurasia
whereas Spain and Italy and Greece are
in like the southwest and basically the
geographical common locations of the
countries also kind of represent their
locations in the park and that's why I
kind of wanted to have a compass in the
middle of this this part thing with path
art and that was really stupid idea but
it was I think it was a good idea just
to like get some kind of excuse to place
that in the middle of my park honestly
just wanted to kind of mess around with
that before I did that though I kind of
wanted to do a little bit of path work
in this little area don't know if it's
really too good really just a bit of a
test but I think it's kind of okay it's
not really too much but kind of works
over there but this is when I got to the
actual part no way no I'm sorry but I
had to do some lights as well that's
also important I mean can't do anything
without any lights also yeah how do we
call it that chair swing battle
going to stay like that sits dessert
stupid hitbox every time I hit that
thing I mean there must be people out
there who also have the ECT of boys and
it's like oh my why does this always
happen like the EC of ours are
absolutely amazing great detail on them
and they're just awesome but the
hitboxes are just built for turn-off
when it comes to that still though I
think it worked kind of good in the in
the middle of this little park area but
it's time to do that pop art work
already what is this Passover at doing
dammit
oh right replacing the borders and
there's this was actually something that
blackout taught me about and like I
always tells me when I [ __ ] up on things
and I definitely kind of done goofed on
this one because I yeah I think the new
borders do look a lot better more
generic and they fit the texture a lot
better and the general I'm just happier
with them one thing that no I'm kind of
unsure about is whether I actually want
to have this money board it's like
there's a lot of border and sidewalk
action going on in the park so far and
it's really not the most amazing thing
ever it's just a bit of a cheap tactic
honestly to make your parts look better
but I just yeah I might just go with it
in the end anyway this is that little
compass thing that I've talked about
really not too much either like there
have been so many people who have done
this thing in path artwork that it's
almost turned into some kind of cliche
but I still hope it good that I could
actually do it in this park just because
I have that geographical kind of theme
to it which I don't know if that's
actually a good idea I just wanted to
get something over here to make this
look better and I suppose in the end
thing kinda did work out and I'm like
doing this I kind of like doing path
work it's not really that hard but you
know it's it's kind of like drawing
doodles things like that it's just fun
to do and a bit of mindless placing you
don't really have to think about too
much you just place this thing place
these things and it's cool but in any
way in any case or anyway that's it for
this episode so thank you all for
watching and I hope to see you on next
episode in which I'll be doing what am I
going to do in the next episode let me
check that um let's play I can't find it
ok we're going to do something what are
we